now to an alarming development in Iowa
after the partial collapse of that
apartment building in the City of
Davenport on Sunday the Survivor was
found a full day after the collapse now
that's the good news but it happened
after officials say the building was
empty and ready to be demolished now
people are wondering if others may still
be trapped inside Roxanna sabiri has the
story
tears echoed through the crowd of
onlookers in Davenport Monday after a
missing woman poked her head out of a
fourth floor window about 24 hours after
her building partially collapsed they're
getting her family say this is Lisa
Brooks firefighters rescued her on
Monday evening hours before the
building's demolition was scheduled for
Tuesday morning a family member said
Brooks hid under the couch when the
building gave way and a reported natural
gas leak may have caused her to pass out
the freaking building just collapsed
when First Responders arrived at the
scene Sunday they discovered the back of
the wall of the six-story building torn
away exposing personal belongings inside
canine teams helped search for residents
and Crews rescued at least eight I have
no uh no known individuals are trapped
in that facility but concerns grew when
the building was set to be demolished
before Brooks was discovered sitting
there my heart dropped to my big toes
her nephew said his family had been
searching for her since the collapse and
now that she's safe they're worried
others may be left behind there are
still people out here and their loved
ones are missing and he's not the only
one on Monday night people protested the
Demolition and demanded accountability
after that crack that figure I decided
it was time to go it comes as a former
resident posted videos complaining of
cracks in the walls and saying the more
than century-old building needed repairs
CBS News has reached out to the landlord
but has yet to hear back the fire
department had ordered the owner to make
repairs and permitted work was underway
for CBS mornings I'm Roxanna saberi